سفير روسيا لدى الولايات المتحده يحذر
واشنطن من خطوره ارسال مقاتلات اف 16 الى
اوكرانيا
قبل ساعات من بدء الهدنه المواجهه تتواصل
والجيش السوداني يطلق قذائف مدفعيه ثقيله
نحو مناطق تمركز لقوات الدعم السريع
السعوديه ترسل رائدي الفضاء ريان برناوي
وعلي القرني الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه لتضع
نفسها في المرتبه الاولى عربيا في مجال
الابحاث الفضاء
[موسيقى]
حييكم واهلا بكم الى هذه النشره الاخباريه
اقدمها لكم انا وحنين الشولي من قناه
العربيه والبدايه من تحضير سفير روسيا لدى
الولايات المتحده انطولي انتونوف واشنطن
من خطوره حصول اوكرانيا على مقاتلات اف 16
ومن ان استخدامها في هجمات على شبه جزيره
القرم
سيعد اعتداء على روسيا وعلى الولايات
المتحده ان تكون على درايه كامله بالرد
الروسي على اي هجوم اوكراني محتمل كما قال
السفير الروسي ان ارسال مقاتلات اف 16 الى
اوكرانيا سيثير تساؤلات ايضا حول ضلوع حلف
شمال الاطلسي في الصراع
بينما تخسر اوكرانيا معركه في حربها مع
روسيا على الجبهه الاخرى تستعد لمعارك
اعتى فانضمام الطائرات اف 16 الى سلاح
الجو الاوكراني كبديل عن طائرات صوفياتيه
اكل الدهر عليها وشرب هي نقطه تحول اخرى
في مسار الحرب الاوكرانيه
لطالما رفضت واشنطن تقديم مقاتلات شرسه
الى اوكرانيا خوفا من التصعيد مع روسيا او
حتى خوفا من تسريب التكنولوجيا التي تعمل
بها الى موسكو وفق السي انا
معتبره ان حاجه تكييف تقتصر على حمايه
البنيه التحتيه وصد الهجمات الروسيه لكن
الضغوط من قبل البنتاجون والكونغرس
الامريكي على مدى اشهر على الاداره
الامريكيه غيرت الدفه بالاتجاه المعاكس
قرار يجسد النظره الامريكيه المتغيره تجاه
الوضع الاوكراني فبينما تنفذ صواريخ كييف
تزداد الحاجه لحمايه الاجواء الاوكرانيه
لكن الامداد بمقاتلات من نوع اف 16 يدل
على تصور واشنطن لمستقبل الحرب
واستمراريتها ربما لسنوات في اوكرانيا حتى
مع التوجه الى حل التفاوض
بالاضافه للتشكيك بالهجوم المضاد الذي
تستعد له
تفوق جوي سيفرض القوه والغلبه لصاحبه
تحاول اوكرانيا الوصول اليه واختصرته على
لسان وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
ديميتروكوليبا في خمس نقاط الحاجه لتطوير
سلاح الجو الاوكراني لصد الغارات الروسيه
التي لا تستطيع انظمه الدفاع الجوي ردها
دعم القوات البريه والتقليل من خسائرها
على الارض بتوفير الحمايه الجويه لهم
حمايه صادرات الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود من
خلال تامين خط تصدير مواجهه مباشره بين
السلاحين الامريكي والروسي لاختبار
القدرات
الحفاظ على الحدود الاوروبيه من ترسيم
روسي قد يغير جغرافيه القاره
حرب تحولت من نزاع على الحدود الجغرافيه
الى حرب استنزاف بين الطرفين الفائز فيها
هو الطرف الذي يستمر في التزويد اللوجستي
لاطول فتره ممكنه
قال يفجني بروجين قائد قوات مجموعه باجنر
الروسيه قال انه لن يكون هناك مقاتل واحد
من المجموعه في الخطوط الاماميه بالمناطق
الاوكرانيه المسيطر عليها اعتبارا من
الاول من يونيو المقبل واضاف بروجين ان
قوات مجموعه فاينر سيطرت على كافه الاراضي
التي تم الوعد بالسيطره عليها في اوكرانيا
يبكيني اكد ايضا ان قواته ستسلم كافه
المواقع في اوكرانيا لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعتبارا من الخامس والعشرين من
ماي القادم
يطلق عليه اسم انتصار مدينه تطلبت 224
يوما من الصراع المحتدم بين فاجنر والقوات
الاوكرانيه ليرفع الروس علامه نصر بارد
بطعم خساره كل ما في المدينه
لكن الانتصار المفترض ياتي في ظل صوره
رماديه ونزاع على تبني الانجاز وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه كتبت كلمه النهايه على
احدى اطول معارك الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا باعلانها السيطره التامه على
مدينه بخمت من قبل قوه فاجنر
على اثر الاعمال الهجوميه لوحدات فاغنر
بدعم من مدفعيه وحده وطيرانها اكتمل تحرير
مدينه ارتيموفسكي
عمل استحق الشكر من قبل الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الذي هنا الوحدات المقاتله
وقوات الجيش التي قدمت الدعم لها بحسب
وصفه شكرا قد لا يبدو ذا اهميه بالنسبه
الذي اشار الى جهد فاجنر المتفرد في
المعركه مصنفا للجيش الروسي الى فئتين
يحترم الاولى منها لما قدمته من دعم شحيح
واخرى وصفها بالمشلوله على حد تعبيره
استغرقت العمليه للسيطره على
224 يوما فوجنر وحدها كانت هنا
وبينما يتقاسم الروس اسباب النصر واطرافه
تنكر السيطره الروسيه على المدينه بالاصل
اعلان بريكوجي السيطره على بخموت ليس الا
وسيله يغطي بها حجم الخسائر التي طالت
قواته
وبالرغم من
تصريحاته في قمه مجموعه السبع والتي تعكس
واقع الخساره في بخمه الا ان مسؤولين
اوكران يصرون على ان وحدات الجيش تحاصر
المدينه بشكل شبه دائري
لم يتبقى شيء هناك باخ متباقيه في قلوبنا
تضارب في التصريحات من طرفي الحرب يوحي
بان الواقع قد يكون انقلابا للادوار بين
من يوجد داخل المدينه ومن يحاصرها واذ
كانت معركه بخموت مشكوكا في اهميتها
الاستراتيجيه ستصبح نهايتها ايضا مشكوكا
عمر العربيه
224 يوما من المعارك الدمويه قتل فيها
الاف الجنود الروس والاوكرانيين في سبيل
السيطره على مدينه بخموت والتي دمرت
تقريبا بالكامل قبل اعلان قوه فاغنار
احكام السيطره عليها ونفى هذا الامر من
قبل ونفي هذا الامر من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه فهل هذه المدينه صغيره التي لم
يتجاوز عدد سكانها السبعين الفا تستحق كل
هذا القتال وما قيمتها الاستراتيجيه
بالنسبه للطرفين
لرفع هذا العالم احتفالا بالانتصار احتاج
الامر تدمير باخمه عن بكره ابيها وازهق
ارواح من عشرين الى ثلاثين الف جندي روسي
وفق معطيات غربيه
ومثلهم من الاوكرانيين وفق معطيات روسيه
القوات الروسيه تحتفل بالانتصار والقوات
الاوكرانيه تنفي
تصريحات بريكوجين ليست صحيحه كما هي الحال
دائما وحداتنا هناك تسيطر على مبنيين
ولديها منشات محصنه في الجزء الجنوبي
الغربي من باخد
يجمع الخبراء ان لا اهميه استراتيجيه
لباخموت كان عدد سكانها 70 الفا فيها
مناجم ملح ومصنع نبيه قديم
القتال في باخم تحول من عسكري الى سياسي
الكرملين بحاجه الى نصر معنوي بعد فشل
القوات في السيطره على اي مدينه منذ الصيف
الماضي
سمعه قوات فاجنر في قدرتها القتاليه على
المحك ورئيسها بريكوجين يقاتل من اجل
الحفاظ على نفوذه في موسكو
استمرت عمليه الاستيلاء على ضخمه مفرمه
اللحم كما يطلق عليها
224 يوما وبدات في الثامن من اكتوبر العام
الماضي لمنح الجيش الروسي المنهك فرصه
للتعافير ولم يكن هناك سوى شركه فاجنر
العسكريه الخاصه لم تكن هناك قوات رسميه
محموله جوا كما زعم المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه او اي شخص اخر لقد ساعدنا
انفسنا بانفسنا
في اوكرانيا اطلقوا على باخ مطلق بحصن
المعنويات استخدمت المدينه لاضعاف الجيش
الروسي وقتل اكبر قدر ممكن من الجنود
وعرقله التقدم نحو مناطق حضاريه اكبر مثل
سلوفيانس وكراماتورز وهي مدن محصنه وسيكون
تقدم الروسي نحوها اكثر دمويه من ضخم
افادت مصادر خاصه بالعربيه بان الجيش
السوداني اطلق قذائف مدفعيه ثقيله باتجاه
مناطق تمركز للقوات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم وياتي القصف المدفعي مع التواصل
اعمال العنف والمعارك في انحاء العاصمه
وبعد ساعات على تعهد طرفي النزاع وقفه
اطلاق النار لمده اسبوع تبدا من مساء
اليوم الاثنين سمع دوي انفجارات في مناطق
متفرقه ومن بينها منطقه الصحافه ومن جانبه
اكد الفريق ياسر العطا عضو مجلس السياده
الانتقالي مساعد القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه تدمير امدادات امدادات قتاليه
متطوره للدعم السريع قادمه من جهه افريقيا
الوسطى
لكن ماذا تضمن الاتفاق الجديد بشان وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان والذي وافق عليه
طرفه النزاع بمحادثه جده تضمن وقف كافه
الهجمات والاعمال العدائيه بما في ذلك
تجميد الهجمات الجويه او استخدام الاسلحه
الثقيله الاتفاق تضمن حمايه كافه المرافق
العامه كالمرافق الطبيه والمستشفيات
والامتناع عن استخدامها للاغراض العسكريه
كما نص على وقف اعمال النهب والسلب
والتخريب واي اعمال تتعلق بالاخفاء القصري
او الاحتجاز التعسفي للاشخاص وتعهد
الطرفان بالامتناع عن التحريض واستخدام اي
مجموعات قبليه او عرقيه في الصرع الدائر
كما يمنع الاتفاق تقييد او اعاقه حركه
المدنيين بمن فيهم العاملون في المجال
الانساني او استخدام المدنيين كدوروا عن
بشريه
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
انطلاق اولى رحلات الحج من اسلام اباد ضمن
مبادرتي طريق مكه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت وكاله مناسبه
الفضائيه انطلاق المركبات دراغون من مركز
كاندي الفضائي مهمه فضائيه الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه وعلامتها اعضاء الطاقه
السعوديين علي القرني وريان برناوي اللذين
يمثلان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
واظهرت لقطات مصوره هبوط ناجحا على الارض
الى قاعده الصاروخ الذي حمل الرواد الى
الفضاء واخرى لرواد الفضاء وهم يختبرون
انعدام الجاذبيه في مقصوره دراغون
نهنئ القياده ونبارك لهم نجاح الاطلاق
وارسال اول رائده فضاء سعوديه وعربيه
ومسلمه واول رائد فضاء سعودي الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه نبارك للوطن بكل فخر
واعتزاز هذا الانجاز التاريخي في خدمه
الوطن والعلم والانسانيه وصدقا لم يكن هذا
الانجاز ليتحقق لولا دعم الكبير والتمكين
من سمو سيدي ولي العهد رئيس المجلس الاعلى
للفضاء قبل عده اسابيع التقى بروااد
الفضاء واكرمهم بكلمات ملهمه ومحفزه هي
وقود الحماس والشغف لدى رواد الفضاء لما
طلعوا الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه هذه المهمه
هي احدى برامج
رواد الفضاء في تبع الخطه السنويه تبع
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للفضاء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اليوم في رصيد المملكه
ثلاث رواد الفضاء فيصير ترتيبنا في على
مستوى الدول مجموعه العشرين التاسع ونحن
الاول على مستوى المنطقه في عهد الفضاء
الذين صعدوا الى المحطه الفضاء الدوليه
رواد الفرج يقوم بعده تجارب علميه عددها
14 تجربه علميه وطبيبيه من اهمها احدى
تجارب برفع الكفاءه علاج السرطان والامراض
المزمنه بالشراكه مع مستشفى الملك فيصل
التخصصي والثاني تجربه جدا مهمه ولاول مره
تقام على محطه الفضاء الدوليه وهي لرفع
كفاءه تقنيه الاستمطار ولها فائده الفائده
الاولى لرفع تقنيات الاستمطار على الارض
ومعالجه التحديات البيئه على الارض
والثاني ايضا لدراسه امكانيه الاستمرار
على الكواكب الاخرى وهذه التجربه والشراكه
مع جامعه الملك فهد والبترول والمعادن
الكواكب
[تصفيق]
شويه
اكد وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود شاويش
اوغلو انه سيكون من الخطا اعاده اللاجئين
الى سوريا من دون التعاون مع الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد وقال تشاوش اوغلو ان
العوده يجب ان تكون تحت السيطره وبمشاركه
الامم المتحده وبدعم المجتمع الدولي بما
في ذلك الاتحاد الاوروبي لافتا الى انه تم
الاتفاق على وضع خارطه طريق تعدها لجنه
خاصه يتبعها ارسال المزيد من اللاجئين
السوريين الى المنطقه الامنه
في مخيم بلاطه للاجئين بالضفه الغربيه
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه في بيان ان
القوات الاسرائيليه قتلت ثلاثه فلسطينيين
بالرصاص وذكرت وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه
ان القوات الاسرائيليه اقتحمت مخيم بلاطه
في مدينه نابلس ومنعت سيارات الاسعاف من
دخول المخيم
قال موقع داونلود ان خدمات تطبيق انستقرام
التابعه لشركه ميثم انقطعت عن مئات الالاف
من المستخدمين وان بلاغات لاكثر من 180
الف مستخدم تحدثت عن وجود مشكلات في
الدخول الى التطبيق في ذروه انقطاع الخدمه
فيما قالت شركه ميثال الملكه للتطبيق ان
الخدمات عادت لمعظم المستخدمين بعد حل
مشكله فنيه
قال رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كاظم انه
سيتلقى سيلتقي بالرئيس جو بايدن بعد ظهر
اليوم الاثنين مع استمرار مفاوضات الحد من
الديون واضاف مكارثي في تصريحات صحفيه ان
مكالمته مع بادا مثمره وياتي ذلك في الوقت
الذي وصلت فيه المحادثات الى طريق المسدود
مع اقتراب نفاد الوقت لتجنب التخلف عن
السداد اذ قالت وزيره الخزانه جانتيلا ان
السيول النقديه للحكومه الامريكيه قد تنفذ
مما يعوقها عن الوفاء بالتزاماتها في وقت
قريب بحلول الاول من الشهر المقبل
غادرت مطار العاصمه الباكستانيه اسلام
اباد متوجهه الى المدينه المنوره اولى
رحلات الحج ضمن مبادره طريق مكه وتعتبر
باكستان من بين الدول التي تحظى بمبادره
الطريق مكه وهي مبادره تهدف الى تيسير
اداء مناسك الحج
مبادره طريق مكه تواصل جهودها في خدمه
حجاج بيت الله الحرام في باكستان للعام
الثاني على التوالي منذ جائحه كورونا
حفاوه وترحيب رسمي حظيت به المبادره مع
ودائع اولى طلائع حجاج باكستان ضمن
المبادره واشاده بدور القياده السعوديه في
خدمه ضيوف الرحمن
نشكر خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان
وولي عهده الامير محمد بن سلمان على
مبادره طريق مكه والخدمات والتسهيلات التي
يقدمانها للحجاج الشعب الباكستاني يكن كل
الاحترام والتقدير للسعوديه ونعتبرها
شقيقا اكبر نظير مواقفها الداعمه لباكستان
العام هذا مستهدف اكثر من 26 الف من مطار
السلامه نعمل ان شاء الله في السنوات
القادمه
التوسع في باكستان الى مطار كراتشي ومطار
لاهور المملكه العربيه السعوديه وعلى
راسها سيدي خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز اسمه سيدي ولي العهد
حريص كل الحرس على خدمه الحجاج وهذا الشرف
لكل مواطن سعودي
اجراءات تنظيميه سلسه ومرنه لقد استحسان
حجاج باكستان الى بيت الله الحرام ضمن
مبادره طريق مكه بين ان الدقائق تمر طويله
على الحجاج الذين يتلهفون بكل شوق للوصول
الى الديار المقدسه في مكه المكرمه
والمدينه المنوره
السعوديه على هذه المبادره وسهوله
الاجراءات هذه اول مره نحجز فيها انا
وسبعه من افراد اسرتي انتظر هذه اللحظه
بعد توفر الامكانات عاقبه تقاعدي تدربنا
على مناسك الحج واكملنا كافه الاجراءات
المطلوبه
هذه المره الاولى التي اسافر فيها خارج
باكستان اشعر بالسعاده والشوق لزياره مسجد
الرسول في المدينه المنوره والكعبه
المشرفه واشكر الحكومتين الباكستانيه
والسعوديه على سهوله الاجراءات وضم
باكستان لهذه المبادره
مبادره طريق مكه تهدف الى تيسير رحله سفر
الحجاج عبر انهاء اجراءات الجوازات وفحص
الاشتراطات الصحيه وتمييز الامتعه في
مطارات بلدانهم وايصالهم الى مقر اقامتهم
في الديار المقدسه
مبادره طريق مكه جزء من خطه طموحه
للارتقاء بخدمات ضيوف الرحمن ضمن رؤيه
2030 والتي تهدف الى اختصار الوقت والجهد
على الحجاج واداء فريضه الحج بكل يسر
وسهوله عبد الرحمن المزيني العربيه اسلام
اباد
تعاني اكثر من نصف بحيرات العالم من موجه
جفاف كبيره من شانها ان تهدد صحه الانسان
وتؤثر على وجود بعض النباتات وذلك بحسب
مجله ساينس العلميه
قوارب غارقه وسفن حربيه قديمه وبقايا
بشريه كلها بدات منذ سنوات تظهر في مياه
بحيره ميد الامريكيه
تلك البحيره التي تتشكل خلف سد هوفر
الشهير بين ولايتين فادا واريزونا وتعد
خزانا حيويا للبلاد انه زمن الجفاف 17
ضعفا لهذا الخزان هو حجم المياه التي جفت
في العالم
مجله ساينس القت الضوء على اكبر كارثه
مائيه يعيشها الكوكب
اكثر من 50% من بحيرات العالم تقلصت
مساحتها بفعل الجفاف خلال العقود ثلاثه
الماضيه وذلك امتدادا من بحر قزوين بين
اوروبا واسيا الى بحيره تيكيكاكا في
امريكا الجنوبيه بحسب مجله ساينس العلميه
تزايد درجات الحراره له النصيب الاكبر من
اسباب تفاقم الظاهره
فمع الاحتباس الحراري هناك ايضا الاستهلاك
البشري وبناء السدود وتراجع معدلات
الامطار بين الاسباب خلف الظاهره المطلقه
صور تقلص المساحات المائيه تحبس الانفاس
25% من سكان العالم يعيشون في مناطق تعاني
بحيراتها من الجفاف او تتبخر المياه في
سدودها ولكن كالعاده الفقراء هم الاكثر
تضررا ودول الناميه هي الاضعف جهزيه
لمواجهه الاثار المدمره مياه تفقد
صلاحيتها للشرب انواع النباتيه وحيوانيه
تختفي والصحه المهدده لدى البشر هكذا
يواجه الانسان زمن الجفاف ذلك الانسان
الذي عايش العصور الجليديه وها هو يواجه
زمن التغير المناخي وحديه المتناقضين
غرقوا الارض
وجفاف المياه
ختامنا نذكركم بابرز العناوين سفير روسيا
لدى الولايات المتحده يحضر واشنطن من
خطوره ارسال مقاتلات اف 16 الى اوكرانيا
قبل ساعات من بدء الهدنه المواجهات تتواصل
والجيش السوداني يطلق قبائف مدفعيه ثقيله
نحو مناطق تمركز لقوات الدعم السريع
السعوديه ترسل رائدي الفضاء ريان برنامج
وعلي القرني الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه لتضع
نفسها في المرتبه الاولى عربيا في مجال
ابحاث الفضاء شكرا جزيلا على حسن المتابعه
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات